well what a packed program i have for
you today starting with economic news as
predicted completely cluelessly by me
feeling around the dark and knowing uh
feeling around in the dark and knowing
absolutely nothing about anything uh
inflation has declined we now have seen
a lower than expected inflation number
this morning this is what i've been
saying for months and since we got the
june numbers in july
inflation year over year after the june
numbers we received in july were at 9.1
percent now we are down to 8.5
coming in below the expected 8.7
now the way that
corporate media reports these numbers
continues to be so confusing look at
this headline from cnbc
consumer prices rose
8.5 percent
in july
less than expected as inflation
pressures ease a bit
this is good news
but the reporting makes it sound like in
july of this year
prices went up
8.5
that is not the case what this number
means is that for the 12-month period
ending in july prices are up 8. 8.5 so
another way to think about it would be
in july we got the inflation numbers
from june 2021 through june 2022 and
that was 9.1 percent now we are adding
the numbers from july 22 and removing
the numbers from june 22. so this new
number is for july 2021 through july
2022 there must be some simpler way to
report this so that people don't get as
confused as they get but the important
thing is
this is good news for an economy that
otherwise looks quite good essentially
full employment
gas prices declining
stock market at least over the last six
weeks looking significantly better than
it had looked in the first months of
2022
a lot of these things look good
again considering that these are the
traditional economic indicators and if
we continue to see an inflation decline
which i expect that we will as as gas
prices in the first 10 days of august
has continued down that is going to be a
very good thing now one other important
bit of news here
real average hourly earnings for all
employees went up
0.5 percent in july so this is another
element that makes the economy look
relatively solid which is not only did
we see inflation decline
we also saw wages go up which this
concern about buying power for the
average american
is mitigated to some degree by prices
down and wages up now is there still
poverty of course is there still hunger
of course inequality of course this
doesn't mean we've solved the economic
problems that we have and that are
inherent to the economic system we have
but by the indicators that we pay
attention to this is a significant
improvement now what's the right wing
story going to be i don't know
i mean listen inflation's down stock
market's up
gas prices are down hourly earnings are
up
somehow it must be very bad for the
country and for joe biden i don't know
what they're going to say probably well
inflation is still too high yeah okay
but it's lower than expected and it's
declining so we'll see what they come up
with
donald trump has finally broken his
silence on the fbi raid of his
mar-a-lago home and he instantly
imploded on his very now extraordinarily
famous platform truth social you know
truth social it's an exciting place
truth essential yeah um so the big news
of course over the last 48 hours that
the fbi executed a search warrant at
donald trump's home in florida they were
in his safe they were in his office they
were presumably in his residence we
don't yet know the full scope of the
search warrant or what they took or what
they were seeking but donald trump
breaking his silence on tuesday with one
post on truth social and then spent most
of this morning posting about it
completely embarrassing post starting
yesterday with quote
a horrible thing that took place
yesterday at mar-a-lago we are no better
than a third world country a banana
republic
people not being above the law is not
exactly
third world stuff
it is a continuation of russia russia
russia impeachment hoax one impeachment
hoax ii the no collusion molar report
and more well that's not true this has
nothing to do with that this has to do
with trump at the end of his presidency
taking documents it has nothing to do
with those other things and then trump
goes on to say to make matters worse it
is all in my opinion a coordinated
attack with radical left democrat state
and local district attorneys and
attorneys general there is no evidence
whatsoever of that and in fact the
report is that biden did not even know
in advance about this then trump
continuing on truth social quote biden
knew all about this
just like he knew about all of hunter's
deals
it does not appear that that is true a
report from politico is that indeed the
biden administration had no advance
notice about the mar-a-lago search could
they be lying sure anyone could be lying
at any time but at this point there is
no evidence that biden even knew ahead
of time about this trump continuing what
took place yesterday and long before was
an unprecedented infringement of the
rights of every american citizen no it
wasn't they had a search warrant they
had a judge sign it the fbi director
presumably knew about it the attorney
general presumably knew about it and
everybody was involved presumably
dotting tease and crossing eyes as who
was it that said the other day i think
it was hannity that said something about
dotting t's and crossing eyes um trump
going on scam after scam year after year
it is all the radical democrats really
know it is their lifeblood they have no
shame and our country is paying a very
big price accountability is a good thing
not a bad thing trump continuing his
tirade quote the fbi and others from the
federal government would not let anyone
including my lawyers be anywhere near
the areas that were rummaged and
otherwise looked at during the raid on
mar-a-lago
everyone was asked to leave the premises
they wanted to be left alone without
witnesses taking or hopefully not
planting
planting there now this is the new thing
planting evidence we'll get to that why
did they strongly insist on having
nobody watching them everybody out obama
and clinton were never raided despite
big disputes what on earth would you
have rated barack obama for i mean it
just quite frankly makes no sense
whatsoever so donald trump exploding on
troth central
and making a dozen or more
unfounded assertions this thing about
nobody was allowed there
look at the commentary from former fbi
agents about what is and is not allowed
during the execution of such search
warrants and you will find that at this
time there's no evidence anything wrong
was done
more very bad news for the failed former
president and and there will be other
bad news for him today as well donald
trump was deposed today
this is major major news and we already
have some reports as to what took place
trump to be deposed wednesday morning in
new york attorney general's probe of his
business this is something trump has
been seeking to avoid for a very long
time
donald trump's deposition for new york's
inquiry into the trump organization is
set for wednesday trump is set to be
grilled in manhattan by lawyers from new
york's attorney general leticia james
james has accused trump of misstating
property values to win tax breaks and
bank loans remember the way that that
works you have a property trump has a
building let's say it's worth two
million dollars when trump wants to use
that building as collateral for a loan
he says this is a three million dollar
building and then when trump wants to
have a lower tax liability in property
taxes on the building he says it's only
worth one million dollars that is
at the nexus at the core of this
investigation the article says donald
trump is scheduled to sit for his
long-delayed court-ordered deposition
wednesday morning we already have a
report about how it went donald trump
claiming that he refused to answer any
questions from the attorney general cnbc
report trump says he refused to answer
new york attorney general's questions
and probe of his business
trump made the announcement shortly
after he arrived at the offices of a.g
leticia james i once asked if you're
innocent why are you taking the fifth
amendment
now i know the answer to that question
remember trump used to say only the mob
takes the fifth why take the fifth if
you're innocent and now donald trump
availing himself of his fifth amendment
right which he reportedly invoked
numerous times today
donald trump also
commenting on truth social in advance of
the hearing quote in new york city
tonight seeing racist new york state
attorney general tomorrow for a
continuation of the greatest witch hunt
in u.s history my great company and
myself are being attacked from all sides
banana republic
no sir i'm coming to you with tears in
my eyes and saying no sir
potentially accountability for anyone
because no one is above the law in the
united states is a good thing in fact
many so-called banana republics sort of
a pejorative trump might sometimes call
them [ __ ] countries uh one of the
hallmarks of many of those countries is
there is not accountability for those in
the top echelons of power and privilege
if there is such accountability in the
united states that would be a good thing
not a bad thing so so much bad news for
donald trump after the break trump uh if
frenetically seeking a criminal defense
attorney
and donald trump's taxes are going to be
given to the house of representatives
could this be the worst 72-hour period
for trump that we can remember
let me know your thoughts find me on
twitter at d pacman and we'll continue
after this short break
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
it has been a wild week for the failed
former president pictures of documents
in his toilet are published the fbi
raids his house he had to testify uh be
deposed by
the attorney general leticia james in
new york this morning at which we now
learn donald trump pleaded the fifth on
every question something he used to say
only the mob and guilty people did and
now there's an extraordinary new report
from rolling stone that donald trump is
desperately seeking
not companionship but a criminal defense
lawyer after that fbi raid inside
trump's frantic hunt for killer criminal
defense attorneys
behind closed doors this summer trump
and his advisors have been narrowing the
shortlist of criminal defense attorneys
he'd need to take on the justice
department the former president has had
preliminary conversations with tim
parletore a lawyer best known for
successfully representing an accused war
criminal about possible legal strategies
should the department of justice
escalate its probe or hit trump with
charges
trump's conversations with parliatore
and other newly retained attorneys are
part of his broader push to assemble yet
another new legal team both for current
legal woes and any future ones coming up
from the fbi and biden era department of
justice trump has been quizzing
confidants what do you think of specific
criminal defense attorneys throwing out
names big and obscure
in other words as one advisor describes
it trump is conducting the apprentice
avoid federal prison edition
monday's fbi raid of mar-a-lago will
likely intensify that search intensify
that search we are going to potentially
see
uh a donald trump over the next couple
of weeks
that is unlike any that we have seen
before
now in terms of representing trump
there's this question of trump is known
for not paying his attorneys so why
would an attorney agree to work for
donald trump well there's two different
answers to that question one
even if they assume they're not going to
get paid because trump stiffs people
it might be worth it essentially pro
bono
not deliberately pro bono but
essentially pro bono after the fact
for the notoriety of representing a
former president that would be one
answer the second part of it is that at
least for now
we still believe that the republican
national committee is paying donald
trump's legal bills remember that early
last week or late the week before i
mentioned to you that the rnc gave trump
an ultimatum
if you declare yourself a candidate for
2024 before the midterms we will stop
paying your legal bills
and it seems that the rnc has decided
both number one that it would be bad for
their midterm chances if donald trump
declares his candidacy too early and
number two that they would rather pay
his legal bills than to have him be i
guess not represented by attorneys in
many of the different problems that he's
having so it's going to be a wild couple
of weeks people have been emailing me
saying what's the timeline on the next
thing like okay there's been a raid
what's the next thing when is the next
thing we don't know the answer to that
but the bad news for trump simply does
not stop
the irs must hand over donald trump's
taxes says a judge
at this point this is more of a ha ha
thing than substantively meaningful if
and until donald trump declares that he
is again a candidate for the republican
nomination in 2024 but this is something
that's been going on for so long think
back to the primary period
in 2016 when donald trump was asked
people with tears in their eyes saying
sir where are your taxes and donald
trump said i'm under audit once there's
no more audit i will release my tax
returns and of course it never made
sense why didn't it make sense well
he obviously wasn't under audit for
every year
why didn't he release the taxes for the
years not under audit because it was all
a lie all along
and a house committee investigating
malfeasance and wrongdoing and
subterfuge
has been trying to obtain donald trump's
taxes for years at this point
this is supposedly the absolute
final definitive
last step
rolling stone reporting irs must hand
trump's tax returns over to the house
committee according to a court judge
david sintel wrote tuesday the chairman
has identified a legitimate legislative
purpose that it requires information to
accomplish oh i don't have this article
here i guess i have to subscribe to
rolling stone
but i can tell you what the
determination is
one of the things that's at issue
when a judge is to determine a question
like
does the irs have to give tax returns to
a house committee
is is there a valid
legitimate
substantive reason
legislatively
for the house committee to have these
taxes if a court believes or determines
that the reason that the house wants
trump or anyone else's tax returns from
the irs
is uh out of curiosity a fishing
expedition to make someone look bad or
for whatever any other reason other than
a legislatively substantive reason they
would say the irs does not have to turn
these documents over
what the court found
is that there is legitimate and
substantive justification
for the house of representatives uh
committee to have those tax returns so
trump is having a really really bad week
i don't know at this point
what would come from a public standpoint
from donald trump's taxes being given to
this house committee but consider
that if he does run again
he is of course going to try to shield
his taxes again i mean listen the guy
won without ever publishing his taxes
which is something no other presidential
candidate has been able to do
and so i'm still interested in seeing
what's there i think that all of the
things we expected would be there
trump's not as wealthy as he claims to
be trump plays very fast and loose with
the values of many of his assets all of
these different things
and what impact they would have on trump
voters at this point is probably almost
zero but what a week a photo surfaced
showing trump flushing documents down
toilets mar-a-lago is rated he has to be
deposed by letitia james and now his
taxes are going to the house committee
not a particularly good week all right
you knew it would happen you knew
that the conspiracy theories would
explode
thanks to this raid at mar-a-lago that
took place of the failed former
president
and one of those conspiracy theories
that is now spreading like wildfire is
that the fbi planted evidence against
donald trump now is there any reason to
believe the fbi planted evidence at
mar-a-lago against donald trump no
is there any specific claim being made
about what was planted
no do we have any reason to believe that
the fbi planted evidence against donald
trump no
but that doesn't stop
them
on the right from saying it the new
trump right-wing talking point is that
evidence was planted this suggests the
reality is almost certainly
that there was no evidence planted and
whatever was found at mar-a-lago is
probably not very good for donald trump
let's look at some examples here is
jesse waters an absolutely horrible
person on fox news
he says the fbi is probably planting
evidence and he goes even further and
says they probably doctored the evidence
to get the warrant in the first place
how horrible is that they could have
easily negotiated the return of
documents like that without guns and
warrants
what the fbi is probably doing is
planning evidence
which is what they did during the russia
hoax
we also have a hunch they doctored
evidence to get the warrant well a hunch
that sounds like it's jesse waters
feeling what's that thing that those
right-wingers always say something like
the facts
don't care
about your feelings and there's a lot of
feelings coming from jesse waters but
very few facts then charlie kirk
interviewed newt gingrich that's a match
made in heaven and again make the
suggestion that the fbi planted evidence
at mar-a-lago do they have any
justification for that claim absolutely
none whatsoever but they're all on the
same page at least as far as the talking
points go uh you really are now seeing
the ugly face of a tyranny uh and the
left is so desperate so frightened and
you're watching trump win again
apparently the last votes came in and uh
his candidate beat
another of the people who had voted to
impeach him so he's now i think i think
he's now defeated seven of the ten
people with a couple devoted to
impeachment right and well in one case
he uh kevin mccarthy talked him out of
challenging uh valedio because they we
wouldn't keep the seat and i think trump
wisely said okay i'm going to give him a
pass
uh the next big test of course will be
uh liz cheney who i suspect will lose by
20 or 30 points
and she's part of this i mean she is
part of the effort to turn the system
into a basically a tyrannical
anti-conservative anti-republican
constant violation of the law which is
what the january 6 commandment now none
of that's true but here's the key moment
you have a fake committee being covered
by the fake news with a fake fbi uh
which by the way you'll notice they
didn't allow anybody on the trump side
into mar-a-lago so we have no idea
whether or not they planted evidence yes
that's exactly right and and newt i have
a couple thoughts number one
they have no idea whether they planted
evidence another way to say the same
thing is we have absolutely no proof
that they planted evidence we have
absolutely no empirical basis for
claiming that they planted evidence and
what we do know is that everything about
the execution of the search warrant was
handled as it always is arguably with
even more discretion because of the
sensitivity of the individual involved
one other example here this is trump
lawyer alina habba
i don't know where all these lawyers
come from there's so many trump lawyers
this is trump lawyer alina habba
she goes on fox news and she also floats
the idea that the fbi planted evidence
there is no evidence that there was
planted evidence this is a joke this is
momento and quite honestly i'm concerned
that they may have planted something you
know at this point who knows i don't
trust the government and that's a very
frightening thing as an american if i
didn't want to be an american and go to
another this is third world stuff we've
heard it this is cuba this is this is
not our country now you know the truth
is
one of the problems with some of the
countries they love to talk about as
third world countries or banana
republics or whatever term they love to
use one of the problems is that there is
no accountability for people in
positions of power and privilege it
distinguishes us if indeed there are
consequences to people in positions of
power and
privilege from those very countries it
makes us different
because in those countries you don't see
accountability
donald trump also by the way floating
this idea that evidence was planted he
went on his platform truth social and he
said quote the fbi and others from the
federal government would not let anyone
including my lawyers be anywhere near
the areas that were rummaged and
otherwise looked at during the raid on
mar-a-lago everyone was asked to leave
the premises they wanted to be left
alone without any witnesses to see what
they were doing taking or hopefully not
planting
why did they strongly insist on having
nobody watching them everybody out obama
and clinton were never rated despite big
disputes
folks
not a shred of evidence presented that
anything was planted they will attack
the fbi they're already doing it even
though the fbi director was appointed by
donald trump and trump gushed about how
great his credentials and honesty and
everything was they will attack the
judge who signed the search warrant i'm
already seeing that this morning they
will attack the doj
as a tool of democratic president joe
biden even though the evidence is the
white house wasn't even informed about
this raid they will attack merrick
garland himself which are all they're
already doing they will attack joe biden
which they're already doing and they
will talk about hillary clinton and
benghazi
they will talk about hunter biden's
laptop they will talk about obama i
don't even know why they're talking
about obama i don't understand why you
would rate obama none of it makes any
sense
and they are doing every single one of
those things now later on we're going to
look at a serious case of brain worms
the new thing is
increasingly the next level conspiracy
theory above and beyond evidence was
planted is this is the beginning of a
plot to assassinate donald trump now if
your plan is to assassinate trump i
don't know why you need to serve a
search warrant first i don't know why
you need to go through the trouble of
legally obtaining the search warrant if
your plan is to assassinate trump it
doesn't pass the sniff test but that has
never mattered to them so we will look
at that a little bit later if you're
curious about some of these clips that
we played during the segment you can
find all of them on our instagram at
david pakman show follow me on instagram
david.pacman as well
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right we are
following the continued meltdown in mega
world over the trump fbi raid this
started monday night during our live
coverage we watched sean hannity
absolutely lose it in some breathless
11-minute monologue about
who even knows what benghazi and obama
and due process who knows what he was
talking about this continued yesterday
and we're going to look at some examples
and you
what's notable about these is obviously
they're running interference for trump
now there's a couple things that can be
going on some of these folks may
themselves be worried
that they could be implicated in the
materials found at mar-a-lago it's
conceivable
the second part of this is
look at how quickly they are willing to
abandon their supposed principles
as soon as they don't like the way
things are going i'm going to give you
one example here here is charlie kirk
seen as a hero to young conservatives
around the country and all this
different stuff
he says well if trump was raided
then they should raid black lives matter
planned parenthood and george soros
why would you raid those things that
doesn't make any sense charlie well
let's see if he explains it
and i'm going to say this plainly and
bluntly raids must be met with raids
they raid donald trump's home well why
don't you go raid blm for burning down a
billion dollars with a property in the
summer 2020. so
each of those property crimes
is being and has been investigated
and
you don't need a raid
if you don't believe that there is
evidence of a crime
at a location like sometimes you would
just arrest somebody you know you don't
necessarily always need a raid in lots
of types of alleged crimes but why would
you start raiding people it doesn't make
sense charlie they rate donald trump why
don't you go raid planned parenthood for
all of their let's just say
very revealing crimes that was revealed
five or six years ago on camera yeah
charlie kirk is referring to
a sort of staged sting operation
that was then used to make false claims
about planned parenthood
and there is no reason that today you
would start raiding planned parenthood
because a legal search warrant was
executed at donald trump's home
they raid donald trump why does george
soros get away with everything he's
doing funding attorney general's offices
well funding attorney general's offices
what crime has taken place charlie
and also
why do they always bring george soros
into this these conspiracy theorists
globalist internationalist trotskyite
socialists unlike obama trudeau mccrone
and the rest of these zio beasts
yeah
um george soros charlie it's a little
bit too on the nose so all of a sudden
due process going out the window just
start raiding everybody
then there's the planted evidence
conspiracy theory we already did a
segment on that earlier in the show but
just to be thorough i am going to play
it again so that we included in this
clip there are ten of these i could play
here's just one this is the planted
evidence conspiracy theory and i won't
subject you to all of it let's just
listen to a little bit of it by 20 or 30
points yes uh and she's part of this i
mean she is part of the effort to turn
the system
into a basically a tyrannical
anti-conservative anti-republican
constant violation of the law which is
what the january six committees you have
a fake committee being covered by the
fake news with a fake fbi uh which by
the way you'll notice they didn't allow
anybody on the trump side into
mar-a-lago so we have no idea whether or
not they planted evidence yes that's
exactly right and and newt i have a
couple thoughts number one i wish i
trusted our law enforcement you need
some form of law enforcement to have a
civil society but i'm right with you i
say oh they're planting evidence how how
disappointing of a place we are in our
country where our immediate reaction is
that our own
law enforcement agency might be planning
evidence against a former president
there is no such evidence there is no
reason to believe that they are planting
evidence there is simply no reason to
believe that and then here's another
talking point that a lot of them are now
uh stuck to and that talking point is
if the fbi can do this to trump they
could do this to anyone no one is safe
this is a very dumb talking point and
i'll tell you why in a moment here's
tennessee republican senator marsha
blackburn using this one i think that
there are a lot of questions that we
justifiably have and we want answers
because if the fbi can do this to
president donald trump they can do it to
you and the american people know that
that is such a silly talking point what
does it mean
if they can do it to trump they can do
it to you
is a president our vips are wealthy
socialites the elites whatever term you
want to use
the bilderbergs no i'm not doing the
jones thing um
are should they be exempt should they
get special treatment and also we know
it can happen to all of us it happens to
all of us all the time that's the whole
point the point is it doesn't happen to
these people at the top echelons of
society that's why it could happen to
you if it happens to trump we know it
could happen to us marsha it happens to
us all the time
the question is will anybody of
significant power
actually be held accountable so brain
worms of major major problem with a lot
of these uh
right wing conspiracy theories
and maybe the most brainwormy of them
all
is the trump assassination plot
conspiracy theory it's so wacky
i want to separate it and talk about it
now in its own right
there is a
growing talking point
that
there is an assassination plot
against donald trump now
almost certainly
there are people who would love to
assassinate
every former president and every current
president uh joe biden gets
assassination threats
trump got them barack obama got more
than any previous president george w
bush got them okay so in some general
sense
the point of the secret service among
other things is to track and pay
attention to and investigate
assassination threats against a former
or sitting president
but there is a growing talking point
among the american right wing the maga
people
that the fbi raid on trump's home
is part of
a growing assassination plot now before
we even look at the clips and the first
clip is going to be from uh from steve
bannon
you have to at some point
apply
some basic level of critical thinking to
this stuff and you should be saying
if there was an assassination plot
against donald trump
why would a legally executed search
warrant on his home
be part of the assassination plot why
why would you need that if you're i mean
for the people that believe that the cia
killed john f kennedy
why would they have needed to first
serve a search warrant on his hyannis
port home or the kennedy compound or
whatever it just doesn't make sense you
don't need a legal fbi raid as part of
an assassination plot but this doesn't
matter to them
this doesn't stop them let's look at
this first clip and by the way if it's
steve bannon so it's not merely an
assassination plot it's a deep state
assassination plot take a look at this
and i agree i do not think it's beyond
uh this administrative state and their
deep state apparatus to actually try to
work on the assassination of president
trump i i think people i think
everything's on the table i think his
security ought to be at the heist has
ever been in and honestly i think he
ought to and i think he should have
flown down in mar-a-lago this morning
walked out there at noon today and said
hey i'm running for president united
states suck on that
well that was my next question as his
former top advisor what should trump be
doing right now right
i think what we did what he should do is
action action action i don't think there
should be any more of the tweets no more
of the true social stuff that's all nice
listen there's not going to be any
tweets he's been banned from twitter for
a long time they put out a video last
night no more videos
we're beyond that
you know they're they're trying to not
just put you in bankruptcy
they're trying to liquidate
uh infowars which is obviously one of
the major news sources out there for uh
the maga movement they're trying to
liquidate
um infowars they're putting peter
navarro in chains like a a common uh
all right so anyway the deep state is
working to assassinate donald trump and
there's been planted materials at
mar-a-lago no evidence of any of that
stuff then on newsmax and we looked at
this earlier in the week here's bernie
carrick and i should actually be precise
about bernie carrick because i alluded
to this and then i was not completely
sure about it
bernie carrick is former police
commissioner
but also a convict he pleaded guilty in
bronk's supreme court to ethics
violations
and acknowledged that when he was
interior minister of iraq he accepted a
quarter million dollar interest-free
quote loan and loan is in quotes it's
not really clear what the deal is with
that then he was indicted by a federal
grand jury the following year in white
plains new york on charges of tax fraud
making false statements in 2009 he then
pleaded guilty to eight felony tax and
false statement charge this guy if this
guy if anybody knows about criminality
it's bernie carrick and he is on to say
i think they may be trying to
assassinate trump with all of this and
again the question is bernie
you used to be in law enforcement
why do you need to execute a search
warrant in order to assassinate someone
and i just put out a tweet about this
if you remember back in 2016 when i when
right before he got elected i was in
washington dc i was at a couple
different social events and i hear
people talking
they said the democrats want this guy so
bad
that they wouldn't put assassination
behind it
and i'm going to tell you something
please they've tried impeachment
they've tried another impeachment
they've tried one investigation after
another this is about one thing
this is about stopping him from running
in 2024. and i'm going to tell you
something i'm not into conspiracies
right i'm not into
anti-government rhetoric
this is the first time in my lifetime
that i would say i am deathly afraid for
donald trump i would not put
assassination
behind these people i i just you know
make a very good point bernie he gets
secret service for the rest of his life
based on what we have known recently
where we hear about deep state he may
find it in his best interest to get his
own security with the secrets
understand that
the deep state may be so deep
it may be in the secret service the
secret service may have it out for trump
and thus trump should have private
security to protect him from the secret
service which is there to protect him
from everybody else says well bernie
about 20 seconds left final thought
listen i couldn't agree more
you know what just happened
is no different than happens in
venezuela colombia cuba and countries
like that unfortunately it really
doesn't happen in a lot of those
countries in a lot of those countries
you would never see a search warrant
conducted
on a current or former official you
wouldn't see it because they actually
don't have the the the administrations
control law enforcement and they control
courts and these are the horrible things
in some of the places that they talk
about so you actually would not see that
no evidence for any of this no evidence
for any of this but they're talking
about planted evidence they're talking
about assassinations they will not stop
and they are throwing everything they
can at the wall to see what sticks we'll
have more coverage of all of this on our
facebook make sure
that you have uh found our facebook page
facebook.com davidpakmanshow and
remember that if you've been missing all
this week we've been doing live streams
covering the latest revelations on all
of this if you've been missing the live
streams you can see the top clips from
the live streams on the second youtube
channel that channel is called
pacmanlive and you can find it at
youtube.com
pacman live believe it or not that's
where you can find it
don't miss the live stream coverage we
will take a quick break and be right
back much more news to discuss today
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right extremely strange news out of
the alex jones defamation trial as many
of you know the
jury found for the plaintiffs in the
alex jones defamation trial for roughly
49 million dollars
alex jones text messages that were
obtained by uh plaintiff's attorney mark
bankston during that trial have now been
turned over to the house committee
investigating the january six trump
riots and the story is going to shift
over there to some degree but there's
now a new wrinkle to the case
uh mark bankston the attorney for the
plaintiffs who will hopefully be joining
me on the show very soon to talk about
all of the all of the trial
he revealed to our friend anna casparian
on the young turks that alex jones sent
what appear to be non-consensual
consexual non-consensual nude images of
his own wife
to roger stone the uh indicted and
pardoned former trump adviser this is
now going from just horrifying to
bizarre
look at this
in the guardian the headline is alex
jones sent nude photo of wife
to roger stone sandy hook lawyer reveals
picture was among cache of messages
inadvertently handed over by infowars
host's lawyer to the opposition legal
team remember this incredible moment
from the trial where it was revealed
that alex jones own attorney
accidentally sent a digital copy of his
entire phone to the opposing council
lawyers for the notorious american
conspiracy theorist alex jones
accidentally gave his legal adversaries
a nude photo of his wife that he had
texted to the conservative political
operative roger stone
the seemingly farcical that i would call
it farcical or kafka-esque the seemingly
farcical but entirely true development
was the latest bit of fallout since one
of the attorneys for a family suing
jones for defamation revealed last week
that jones owned lawyer inadvertently
handed over numerous text messages the
lawyer mark bankston the recipient of
the leak appeared on monday on the young
turks to confirm one of the texting
questions
um contained a naked photo of jones wife
sent to stone now since there's been a
commentary from alex jones wife alex
jones wife says she is unaware
and upset her husband sent a nude photo
of her to roger stone so indeed it was
sent
non-consensually what we don't know is
whether the picture itself was
non-consensual there's a little bit of a
gray area alex jones might have taken
the picture consensually and sent it to
roger stone without consent or even the
existence of the picture itself might be
non-consensual uh let's take a listen to
the
clip from mark bankston speaking to the
young turks mr jones said that there was
an intimate photo of his wife on the
phone that i can also confirm that's
true and i normally wouldn't talk about
that in public um but there is a public
interest angle into this is that i'm a
little concerned about it because that
intimate photo was sent to roger stone
and i don't know if that was consensual
and if it wasn't consensual and mrs wolf
jones should know about that and there
might be something that needs to be done
about that then again it could be
totally consensual but when i see that
and i don't see any indication that it
was um i'm concerned something might not
be on the up and up with that there are
certainly laws in certain states about
that yeah and in fact we've since found
out thanks to the uh cl comment
from erica wolfe jones she was not aware
of the exchange and was upset about the
disclosure
the wife of conservative radio host alex
jones told insider tuesday she was
unaware her husband sent a nude photo of
her former of her to former donald trump
advisor roger stone
um
we're gonna try to get mark bankston on
the show very very soon to talk about i
think that there are probably a dozen
other
bizarre
major interesting stories
underneath what is currently publicly
known about this and it's so strange to
think i've told the story before back
when i met alex jones years ago
at a talk radio event called the
talker's new media seminar
he really first of all
his physical appearance was far more
normal he also spoke far more normally
in what was not like an on-air capacity
he was still the wacky guy on air
but behind the scenes we were just
chatting and i was on the outskirts of
this small group of four people who were
who were chatting i had not met him
before
he seemed to even acknowledge
the way that he's perceived saying after
the speech he gave
you know i could have really freaked him
out if i'd wanted to sort of like
acknowledging that he toned down his
character because it was sort of like an
industry event or whatever
now every video of alex jones outside of
his show whether it's someone going up
to him on the street or the testimony
that he gave under oath during the trial
that just completed
it seems as though there is now really
no difference between the on-air alex
jones and the off-air alex jones and it
is dramatically different than what i
experienced personally
uh i mean i guess at this point it was
like 12 years ago
so i don't know what to make of it but
it wouldn't come as a shock
if indeed there was this predatory
aspect to alex jones as well where he is
non-consensually sending nude pictures
of his wife to people all
extraordinarily bizarre
you know uh there's this theme that
we've been following in the republican
party over the last many years
allegations are confessions now of
course we're not literally saying it
it's not strictly true
but many of the things that republicans
accuse the left of doing we later find
out they themselves are actually doing
and one of those things is that a
trump-endorsed republican has been
caught tampering with voting machines
despite being a big
uh
one of the people crying wolf
when it comes to
voter fraud reuters reports trump-backed
michigan attorney general candidate
involved in voting system breach
documents show
this is about the republican nominee for
michigan attorney general his name is
matthew deperno
he led a team that gained unauthorized
access to voting machines while hunting
for evidence to support trump's claims
about election fraud understand that
in searching for evidence of election
fraud
you end up tampering with voting
machines and accessing things that
you're not supposed to
the analysis shows that people working
with matthew diperno examined a vote
tabulator from richfield township a
conservative stronghold of 3 600 people
in michigan
the richfield security breach is one of
four similar incidents being
investigated by the current ag democrat
dana nessel under state law it is a
felony to seek or provide
unauthorized access to voting equipment
deperno did not respond to a request for
comment
the involvement of a republican attorney
general nominee
in a voting system breach comes amid a
national effort by backers of trump's
fraud falsehoods to win state offices
that could prove critical in deciding
any future contested election understand
the what what this is okay
matthew deperno is running for attorney
general
were he to win that race
he would be involved generally speaking
in supervising future elections in
michigan
and at least theoretically in
prosecuting real instances of voter
fraud election tampering etc
and he himself now has been allegedly
caught
tampering with voting machines
and accessing things he is not supposed
to have access to
and all of it was done because he's
looking for voter fraud that actually
doesn't exist
here is a clip of donald trump a few
months ago very strongly praising matt
deperno check this out
somebody said well he's very tough
that's what you need
who is putting his life and reputation
on the line right matt diperno
after the 2020 election
matt led the explosive investigation to
what happened in antrim county where
among other irregularities
votes were switched by mistake
and had to be corrected none of it
happened okay so anyway the guy trump
really likes to investigate
all of the fraud done against trump is
now accused of tampering with voting
machines you really can't script this
stuff you truly cannot
let's hope this guy doesn't win because
if he does then the temperer will be in
charge of prosecuting the voter fraud
that may or may not take place that
doesn't sound very good we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p i am shocked by the outpouring
of messages yesterday on the bonus show
yesterday oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
right we made money on the bonus show
yesterday and we talked about manual
transmissions in cars and i said
my first vehicle when i got my license
was a 1991 pontiac firebird and i know
you would not expect a jewish
argentinian to be driving a pontiac
firebird culturally it doesn't make any
sense i get it guys but that was my
first car i got a great deal on it i
have to tell you
and um i indicated that for me it's sort
of sad that manual transmissions are
going away particularly with electric
vehicles which don't even have gearboxes
we are seeing a decline in the number of
availa available vehicles with a manual
transmission this is not you know this
is not kids going hungry it's just an
element of nostalgia and i said
yesterday that i didn't love it i got so
many emails from people saying david i
love stick shifts here's how here's you
can do this that the other thing and
here is a piece of advice that i got
about this stick shift issue
yes hello david this is yabbitz from
marietta georgia i heard your show i
heard your bonus show i heard your
manual transmission uh
well i don't know jeremiah i don't know
what it is sort of a lament it was
motorcycles i got one word for you
motorcycles
ain't going to be
manual transmission is going to be on
motorcycles for as long as i can imagine
i gotta believe it
so uh and by the way
one of my favorite films
based out of arjun
um
argentina yes
is motorcycle diaries right i don't know
if you ever saw it but man what a great
fantastic film
but
i i learned in the 1960s to drive
a stick shift on the steering wheel on
the handle as well as four on the floor
i know manual very well and i love it
all right so listen here's the deal i
don't know how many people in the
audience know this i used to have a
motorcycle when i was i want to say
about 18
i bought a used honda cbr 600 from a
friend of mine
it was so cool it was fun it was great
and then one day
i just realized
this is absolutely insane this is so
dangerous this is crazy
and i sold the motorcycle and i love
never looked back and now in particular
knowing a bunch of emergency room
doctors
and hearing from them listen
don't get a motorcycle it's insanely
dangerous i know you only live once and
all this different stuff
it seems like an insane risk so i get it
stick shifts on motorcycles it's a
beautiful thing it's not going to be for
me it is just so outrageously dangerous
and i'm not denying that it's fun i'm
not denying that it's great but it's not
for me so for me my stick shift driving
will be limited to i i think
at a certain point if and when you know
my household needs a second vehicle i
think i would prioritize something with
a manual transmission for nostalgia
purposes okay thank you very much
on today's bonus show we will talk about
the results from last night's primaries
in wisconsin minnesota vermont and
connecticut we are going to talk about
an attempt
by u.s lawmakers to crack down on
airlines for cancelled flights it is
bonkers what's been happening with
canceled flights recently and we are
also going to bring back the discussion
about a national popular vote it is now
abundantly clear
most americans support a national
popular vote they just do and there are
a number of different ways that we can
get there some easier than others we
will talk about the pros and the cons of
a national popular vote of using the
popular vote to decide who becomes
president of the united states all of
those stories and much much more
await you on today's bonus show you can
sign up for the bonus show at
joinpacman.com
you can use the coupon code big voting
22 something we must all do to get a
discount off of the cost of a membership
so i will see you on the bonus show
today or otherwise on tomorrow's show
you